la palabra desigualdad por sí misma
suena algo injusto pues no todos están
recibiendo lo mismo ya sea el mismo
ingreso o la misma riqueza pero aquí la
pregunta a hacerse es esto es
necesariamente algo malo y aún cuando
sea algo malo las formas para arreglarlo
o mejorarlo podrían empeorar las cosas
especialmente para las personas a las
que se trata de ayudar nuevamente mi
objetivo aquí no es decirles cuál es la
solución sino darles un marco de
referencia para que ustedes piensen en
ello imaginemos un mundo en el que se
tiene una economía de pastel fijo y el
incremento de la desigualdad no ayuda en
nada a las personas que tienen menos
recursos vamos a dibujar
este rectángulo representa todo el
ingreso nacional durante cierto período
que es
un año o el año 1
este es el ingreso
nacional
total ingreso nacional total digamos que
en el año 1 el 10 por ciento de los
perceptores reciben una tercera parte
del ingreso nacional que representa el
ingreso de las personas que más ganan
aunque permítanme aclarar que esta área
de que no es el 10% de todo el
rectángulo ésta es una tercera parte del
rectángulo que representa el ingreso del
10% superior 10% superior y con 10%
superior me refiero al 10% de la
población con mayores ingresos lo que
significa que el otro 90% restante se
reparte en las dos terceras partes que
quedan del ingreso nacional si vemos la
realidad de todo el pastel hagamos un
pastel estático por acá y cuando hablo
de pastel me refiero a este rectángulo
de acá aquí tenemos un ingreso nacional
estático
dibujemos otro rectángulo del mismo
tamaño y si tenemos un aumento en la
desigualdad en esta situación entonces
podríamos tener que el 10% superior no
se digamos que este es el año 10 en
lugar de tener una tercera parte del
ingreso nacional ahora van a tener el
50% de este aquí estoy inventando
números para simplificar si eso sucede
entonces el otro 90% se va a repartir el
50% que queda del ingreso nacional
este es el caso de una economía estática
que no tienen nada de crecimiento por lo
que el aumento de la desigualdad
significará que el otro 90% tendrá un
menor ingreso per cápita del producto
interno bruto y tendrá una estándar de
vida mucho más bajo no les va a ir bien
en esta situación pero ahora pensemos en
otra situación donde hay un crecimiento
de la economía suficiente como para que
aunque exista desigualdad el crecimiento
lo equilibre por lo que al otro 90% le
va a ir mejor veamos si podemos
visualizar aquí tenemos un crecimiento
económico crecimiento económico por lo
que ahora nuestro pastel ha crecido
dramáticamente en estos 10 años esta
economía se ha duplicado en esta
situación seguimos teniendo desigualdad
iniciamos con que tenían una tercera
parte en el año 1 y para el año 10
tienen el 50% del ingreso
lo que sigue creciendo la desigualdad
sin embargo el 50% del ingreso nacional
que queda para el otro 90% también ha
crecido dramáticamente vamos a copiar y
pegar estos dos tercios del pastel del
año 1 que fue lo que se repartieron en
el año 1 el otro 90% si lo comparamos
con el del año 10 vemos que este primero
es mucho más pequeño suponiendo que la
población no ha crecido en la misma
proporción entonces el ingreso per
cápita del producto interno bruto va a
mejorar por lo que esta es una situación
en la que aún cuando hay crecimiento en
la desigualdad esas personas están mejor
aquí lo escribimos
esto nos lleva a una de las cuestiones
fundamentales en especial en los
sistemas económicos donde tenemos un
sistema capitalista esta economía de
mercado mercado en donde la historia
reciente nos ha mostrado que será un
crecimiento de la riqueza aquí hay un
crecimiento económico
pero también ocasiona desigualdad va a
ser una consecuencia inevitable la
desigualdad una pregunta que podrían
hacerse es esto algo malo necesariamente
pues si el crecimiento económico es
suficiente todos se van a beneficiar sin
importar que unos se beneficien más que
otros algo importante considerar es lo
que sucede si solo nos enfocamos en
eliminar la desigualdad pues también se
eliminará el crecimiento económico otra
forma de pensar en ello es que si tú
eres de las personas que se encuentran
aquí con el otro 90% preferiría
permanecer en este mundo del pastel
estático sin crecimiento económico y sin
crecimiento en la desigualdad o
preferirías estar en este otro mundo de
aquí nuevamente el punto de este vídeo
no es decirles que mundo es mejor ya que
podría existir un mundo en donde el
crecimiento total es más pequeño que
esto y al otro 90% no le va a ir bien el
punto de este vídeo es resaltar
que la desigualdad no necesariamente
significa que las personas que tienen
menos participación en el ingreso
siempre les vaya a ir mal sobre todo si
el pastel crece lo suficientemente
rápido y la otra cosa a tomar en cuenta
es que a veces en el intento de
disminuir la desigualdad podría también
frenar el crecimiento económico lo que
podría ocasionar que a todos les vaya
mal así pues todo depende del contexto
de la situación de las variables y los
números que estemos viendo aquí solo
quiero hacer énfasis en que el
crecimiento de la desigualdad no
necesariamente implica que va a afectar
negativamente al otro 90% aunque sin
duda beneficia más a los que se
encuentran en el 10% superior pero
también debido a que esto es un
subproducto del crecimiento económico
podría ser que le vaya mejor a estas
personas también